all right canada's freedom convoy is
still going strong tonight and it's
spreading all over the world europe new
zealand here in the u.s building support
gaining momentum standing up against
one-size-fits-all medicine even amid
relentless baseless attacks from the
biden of the north the gutless the
cowardly justin trudeau who continues to
refuse to meet with the truckers and
hear their valid concerns and we're
continuing to learn more about the
convoy disrupting a u.s canada border
crossing as essential workers now
continue to make their voices heard by
the way that's about 300 million dollars
of commerce daily uh that stopped so uh
what are you gonna do justin joey i know
you're asleep when you wake up maybe
somebody can ask you in the morning what
are you going to do and to our friends
in canada i can tell you with a high
degree of certainty that joe biden is
asleep he's had his cup of warm milky
and probably won't even know or remember
the story in the morning here on the
ground in ottawa with the very latest
investigative reporter fox news
contributor sarah carter sarah first
thing please tell these truckers that
they the american working people and
this people in this country
stand in solidarity with what they're
doing and for the freedom movement that
they're leading
that's absolutely right sean i can't
even begin to tell you how warm the
welcome was here for me and how open
everyone's been you can hear them seeing
the national anthem the american
national anthem in the background they
were seeing the canadian national anthem
they're here for freedom and they are
frustrated and they are a bit angry at
the way prime minister justin trudeau
has described them and what they say is
fake news about them take a listen to
this
there's been a lot of talk about people
here than truckers not being uh kind uh
that there's a lot of violence that
they're racist are you what are you
seeing i i would say that's that's
baloney they're not showing the truth so
they're not showing the whole picture
how frustrated are you with that
because i i i that's what i've been
getting from everybody here
because you only see one side of the
story they're only painting the pictures
of that one those few bad apples out of
the bunch so just leave us alone let us
be open it up what do you have to say to
prime minister trujillo
he should be out he should have came out
and talked to everybody at the very
beginning instead of calling people
nazis and there's nobody like that here
he's got to listen does it surprise you
that the prime minister and others are
trying to threaten people who are
helping you
i'm not surprised by that
when you don't
have anything on anybody's tend to call
names and make things up that's what
they're doing do you feel it's the
governments that are really dividing the
people 100 yeah the one thing trudeau
has really truly done is united the
people against him yeah
and what he's tried to divide this
country
but he has brought unity with
this convoy here unity and
against him this is global now the
entire world is watching we've had you
know support from the european
parliament from
from nations everywhere everywhere it's
global and people are waking up and
we're trying to to show that to the
world that this is a unified front it's
all of the people
and there's no stopping this now
sean i gotta tell you the people here in
canada the truckers say they are tired
of living like prisoners in their own
homes for the last two years they say
nobody is going to be able to make them
move until the prime minister lifts the
mandates and lifts the mass mandates and
the vaccine mandates and they are
you can hear that yeah they love you
they love you sean they love you
well sir do me a favor before you go on
my own
plea please tell them
that
me and and many of the viewers of this
show if not the vast overwhelming
majority we support what they're doing
we thank them for being peaceful and
standing up to their gutless and
cowardly prime minister and
i hope they stay there till they win
you can tell them i'll wait i gotta tell
you guys sean sends a message he sends a
message he says we are standing beside
you he is standing beside you
and he wants you and is grateful that
you are sending
sending a message to your gutless prime
minister who won't face you so
you tell them what they got to say
okay but by the way lastly don't tell
them i'm a new york grain
don't tell them i'm a new york rangers
fan that may not go over as well uh
oh no that won't go over well i'll go
over there myself thanks okay sarah
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else